[Musique]
Port-Gentil la capitale pétrolière et
économique du Gabon cette ville côtière
construite sur la presqu'île de Mandji
n'est qu'à 4 mètres au-dessus du niveau
de la mer alors que l'océan ne cesse de
monter
symbole de cette montée des eaux le
phare du Cap Lopez sorti des ateliers du
célèbre ingénieur français Gustave
Eiffel aujourd'hui avec l'érosion
côtière la mer menace d'engloutir ce
monument de fer et de cuivre tout comme
d'ailleurs toute la ville de Port-Gentil
voir sa ville submergée une effroyable
perspective à laquelle ne peut se
résoudre Henri Michel aux côtés d'autres
militants écologistes il vient
surveiller chaque semaine le niveau de
la mer avec comme baromètre cette digue
érigée il y a quelques années et censé
protéger la ville contre l'inexorable
montée de l'océan
même si ça a coûté de l'argent mais ça
sera la moins chère
déplacer par gentil le poumon économique
du pays une solution radicale à laquelle
espère encore échapper les habitants de
la ville même s'il subissent de plus en
plus les inondations notamment les moins
nantis logés dans ses habitations de
fortune
dans ce quartier précaire Fatima et ses
voisines vivent sur le qui vivent avec
les fortes pluies qui ont multiplié les
épisodes d'inondation elles utilisent
désormais ses palettes pour se frayer un
chemin jusqu'à leur domicile
nous aident à accéder à la maison au
lieu de tremper les pieds dans l'eau
sorti de la douche ici nous sommes à
Port-Gentil c'est entouré d'eau on va
nous déplacer ici pour nous amener où
qu'elle est là où on peut nous mettre
qu'on ne trouve pas l'eau vraiment ça
c'est difficile pour nous ici pour
éviter d'avoir à planifier un
déplacement de la ville les autorités
municipales mettent les bouchées doubles
pour tenter de limiter les risques
d'inondation la mairie est engagée dans
une course contre la montre pour réparer
le réseau de drainage des eaux pluviales
un labyrinthe de 20 km de long jusqu'ici
obstrué par des déchets
vous avez commencé à quelle heure
à quelle heure
8h ok donc là on a commencé ici
des travaux menés sous la supervision de
Racine Rogon B le directeur technique de
la municipalité ce chantier de drainage
de Port-Gentil va coûter au moins 50
millions d'euros et il faudra encore
plus d'argent pour sauver la ville de la
montée des eaux
par la mairie toute seule parce que ça
demande beaucoup de moyens donc on aura
besoin d'être appuyé par des partenaires
internationaux ou encore l'état central
pour venir en aide à la mairie à
Port-Gentil on a contacté un phénomène
particulier c'est la conjugaison la
conjugaison de de grandes marées et des
forces pluies qui font que les eaux
montrent davantage et on a les ouvrages
ont du mal à évacuer les eaux donc ça
les obstacles plus longtemps
la montée des eaux pourrait menacer les
principales installations pétrolières de
Port-Gentil qui contribuent à hauteur de
40% au PIB gabonais d'où la tension
particulière portée à ce dossier par les
scientifiques du pays
à 700 km de la ville les chercheurs du
Centre national des données et de
l'information
océanographique de l'Université
Omar Bongo de Libreville surveille jour
après jour les effets du changement
climatique sur les courants océaniques
le bleu foncé c'est les faibles courants
le bleu on va venir claire voilà c'est
le courant intermédiaires et ensuite le
verre va tendre vers le rouge le rouge
ma gloire désirée muganga est un
géomorphologue du littoral un
spécialiste dont les prévisions à
l'horizon 2050 prennent en compte le
scénario du pire si le pire arrive la
première chose qui va avoir c'est
l'exacerbation du phénomènes d'érosion
l'exacerbation des phénomènes
d'inondation parce que avec une côte
d'altitude aussi basse
les eaux auront du mal à circuler et si
les ont du mal à circuler
malheureusement
il y aura un engorgement qui va qui va
se faire et au rythme où l'érosion se
fait aujourd'hui avec l'ouverture de
nombreuses brèches et tout le reste je
pense que l'horizon 2050 risque d'être
un indicateur qui va marquer
malheureusement les signes de la
progressive reconstruction du paysage de
l'îlemangi
pour l'île mondier Port Gentil les
prévisions scientifiques n'exclut pas en
2050 une montée des eaux supérieure à 6
mètres soit bien au-dessus du niveau
actuel de la ville la projection fait
frissonner les scientifiques et ils
l'ont baptisé la grande menace fantôme